there were fewer rail workers than usual
at paris's gal de leon train station
because many were on strike to demand
higher wages staff say that they've not
had a pay rise in nearly a decade and
with a rising cost of living they're
struggling financially
we are on salaries and like many
employees we see the cost of living
going up but our salaries don't go up so
it doesn't add up
more than a third of france's train
services were cancelled causing
disruption for some travellers at the
start of the summer break
it is annoying for us as passengers but
the right to strike is a fundamental one
and i sympathize with their demands
with the holidays the strikes a bit
complicated also just after covert but
everyone has to defend their rights the
french government says that it cannot
raise people's wages but it is planning
a number of measures to help people with
inflation as part of a new cost of
living bill
the proposed law includes financial help
for poorer households with fuel and food
president emmanuel macron's government
no longer has a parliamentary majority
and has urged the opposition not to
block the bill
we will propose to extend the cap on gas
and electricity prices to increase
income from work and to lower charges on
the self-employed by tripling the upper
limits of the purchasing power bonus and
increased pensions and social benefits
the rail strike is expected to last one
day but with french airport workers
planning their third strike in a month
later this week it is clear that some
people's travel plans may not stay on
track natasha butler al jazeera paris